let's go brother welcome to gob I played
this long ago I was I think it was just
an alpha back then so let's see what has
changed I remember oh it does look a lot
different uh hey [ __ ] this place it's
actually really creepy
alright let's go to that house I'm sure
everything will be fine no buddy it's
very pretty
last time I played through the oculus I
can't play with the office anymore it
makes me so sick that is just alright
everybody hey someone is breathing hello
no it's me somebody definite its
breathing ok I definitely hear someone
breathing oh god oh god there's someone
in there that's [ __ ] up main
oh what a year oh I find a match
what what are you there's no electricity
but it lets make sense okay you know
what I got I know what we're gonna do
we're gonna burn up these so we can let
him escape all right we better find some
more matches oh this is where I came
from
Oh God hello no it was this my Brian
we're back in the desert
why
ah stop stop
god damn is he gone now oh it's still
chilling I have infinite matches badly
make it rain make it rain numb them
house okay well this oh that looks great
that's going there I still got my
mattress though so it should be fine
it's just a creepy cave we've done word
spreads like that one time Oh God I'll
[ __ ] this we're still fine hello
make it rain [ __ ] make it rain
I got so much magics I don't know how to
stages but I'm making it rain anyway
girl I'm making that rain anyway hi so
we made it out okay this this scenery
kinda reminds me of a TAS the Tasmanian
Devil it's maybe just me I don't know oh
great times that means there's gonna be
an electricity that means when the night
comes with [ __ ] an alien or two [ __ ]
what thank you make it rain make it rain
make it rain down somehow what all right
for fine maybe I need to throw it around
no threw it to it come on come on dad
give it uh-huh okay guess what do I do
with I why would I have a gas can
oh because I can do this
make it rain yeah whoa awesome I made a
little fire I bet they're scared of fire
maybe that's the thing or some [ __ ]
Jenna it's getting Derek what's out
there
Oh God okay oh good we're so feet oh god
it's so how [ __ ] fast you to get dark
oh my god what is that oh job not a feet
done what was that oh god it's that
Eagle watch what now I'm pretty good
I'd say 10 out of 10 best game ever next
time we'll make them burn
I'll be ready next where's my gasps
where's my guest
where's my what is that arm doing though
oh hello
whatever this batteries when the mom is
gone and you can't go on Matt Reed
what's that shut up okay we're not gonna
pick up that cuz that triggers mean
things I want my gasoline I really did a
lot of improvements from next time I'm
excited this is actually just a
Kickstarter
demo so oh [ __ ] not the [ __ ] flares
all right maybe the gas was just like a
one pen oh there's a generator that's
what I was supposed to use the gas for
I'm stuck not the whole game I hope
maybe now we can get the gas up my
Janice you thought it was gonna say
house oh god it gets starts so [ __ ]
fast I don't like this alright how about
here
great times loved it kind of done you
know what let's burn the entrance so
they can come in [ __ ] genius burn
baby burn
wait now I can't exit ok ok ok
hello alright well I guess I'll just go
on a midnight stroll I have nothing
better to do anyway for big on spot of
shotgun all right fine yep fine this is
Eagle Eagle Eye cherry baby what is that
light over there I wish I had binoculars
should I check it out or should I just I
love this [ __ ] spook this is so
[ __ ] creepy man Jesus oh god I see
one I think no maybe not I don't know
nobody came out of nowhere
begotten sputters oh oh oh oh what's up
what
take my matches matches matches matches
matches okay it's not really working is
it all right I can define myself
are you lamp all right what's up are you
doing all alone here I got ya
really we just met you [ __ ] [ __ ] I
don't
okay now you just [ __ ] alright you
know what Oh a TV great laughing I got a
battery
and I got some flats let me get on my
flat for that hi flashbang all right
cool
well he's that when I make it rain baby
what you gotta know about this shampoo
easy this game is easy what you're gonna
know you ain't got much whites it why so
bad egg he shot Bernie why is he not
burning take the flap nice rough where
you work out breath well that one great
did I lose all my [ __ ] I lost all my
shape oh good just be dying at my
alright
[ __ ] be dying awesome they can't
touch it you can't touch me I'm in the
light baby I'm like awesome okay they're
all burning oh god oh god oh god
see ODC jab that's never fun
oh my god what is that but it's like a
Oh God Oh fun
you're not pretty I'm pretty like a
match my god shoosh shoosh all right I
think we made it and what we needed
oh god the canal burn
what's up I'm not gonna get pregnant
alright that was fun I really know
what's going on thank you for playing
the demo nailed it
alright so they have a Kickstarter I
think it's finished but you can check it
out if you want I'll leave a link to
description hope you enjoy watching I
was booked see we did a lot of things
today
I'm very proud of myself and you a
little bit alright maybe doing watching
Russ it helps always so thank you and
I'll see you tomorrow
have you read